pack some Universal routine my name is
agent mundo of the FBI this is deputy
director Brian Julien Perkins Paxton
University athletic director campus
security alerted me to your visit you
want to tell me what this is all about
we have a warrant to search the crew
teams electronic devices we have reason
to believe one of them is a rapist in
the murder the assault victim is
currently missing this is ridiculous
can't just come in here and make those
kind of accusations do you even have any
proof it's an ongoing investigation you
don't get to ask that question who are
you to say Finn that's enough keep your
mouth shut
okay I'll handle this there's not the
first time that one of my athletes has
been wrongly accused of sexual assault
these lies ruin reputations fewer than
10% of all rape accusations are false
that statistic agent Ryan has nothing to
do with these fine young men not one of
them is capable of rape or murder
if you're so sure they're innocent the
devices will prove it but you won't be
taking their devices according to
university council their computers
phones their tablets they're all
protected under the Family Educational
Rights and Privacy Act they contain
confidential student records they're not
interested in a calculus course we're
looking for evidence in a criminal
investigation as you know the laws the
law well you can have access to their
devices so if you obtained consent or
probable cause for an arrest it warrants
they're useless we will find out what
happened here you can't protect them
forever